[Applause]
we're back with medium anna ramondi
who says she has the ability to connect
with the afterlife
and we were very excited to meet her
because apparently she's got the goods
and i have to say i'm intrigued
i am a little bit of a skeptic but i
also
believe in everything so
i have the most open mind and open heart
uh i really do um so i'm really excited
to be a part of this
and you're going to be reading for one
of our
vff's today who lost her husband six
years ago
holly hi hi anna hi drew
hi first holiday i'm
i'm so sorry for your loss um and
i'm excited to be a part of any
liaisoning
so i'll turn you over to anna for your
question
okay thanks anna my question to you is
when i'm having a bad day i often see my
husband's car
and my question is what does this mean
what is he trying to say to me
first of all your husband has been
coming through to me since last night
um he has an awful lot to say um you
know he shows you the car
because you a you recognize it you know
that's him
that's coming through um second of all
do you have a son whose name begins with
a j
yes and he's driving
yes he is yes because um he wants you to
pay attention to how your son is driving
he's okay
but sometimes he's distracted he's
coming through with somebody named nancy
do you know who nancy is i do know
exactly know who nancy is
nancy uh is the um
wife of my partner who passed away from
ovarian cancer
so my partner's name is tully and both
of us got together because we lost our
spouses
and both to cancer and both had young
children um
they brought you two together okay they
like the venture that you're in
whatever you're doing together um is
very blessed
okay are you in business with him as
well because i'm and your husband likes
hot dogs
um he's saying i like does this make
sense to you
yes we own a restaurant together and we
sell hot dogs
he likes them he's also thanking you for
allowing him to go home
when he passed um he didn't want to draw
it out
he didn't want to make it long i don't i
feel like you know
you know you he's saying you suffered
more than he did
okay um and he's sorry for that but he's
completely
completely around you and great job with
the boys
thank you i'm blown away right now
you could not have known certain things
about this there's no way
that's incredible thank you
so much welcome thank you holly
wow okay i am like um
i have to admit i can't is it is it
appropriate for me to ask you something
sure uh what do people do they tend to
ask you
about people who have left that they can
no longer
have the ability to communicate with
well yeah except that you know you can
communicate to whomever you want
you just start talking do you know who
ruth is
grandmother grandmother line you or
husband's side ex-husbands oh my god yes
okay who is this person because she's
really around you uh i love her
she's um will's grandmother okay
because you are so a part of that family
um
it doesn't matter whether the two of you
are not together anymore
and she's so proud of um how you're
raising your daughters
and so proud that you are still a part
of them
okay very very very happy um she's also
there's another woman coming through
um i i don't know no there's a judge
who's the judge
there's a judge there's somebody oh my
god david
david who is this that's ruth's son who
died
okay they are together okay they're
together but this family is completely
around you okay like you're so pulled
into your family
like you needed this family so are you
still very close to them
yeah i'm really really close with will's
family did you i want my girls to have
that
but they do do you know his mother
sister she also passed
um there's a sister that passed does she
have two sisters
oh my oh coco yes oh my god and one of
them has passed
yes um did you know her these are very
pretty women
um yeah because she's going somewhere i
don't know where she's going
but she's she's very happy and they're
calling you their own
this is just this is crazy yeah yeah
yeah are you gonna be with them i mean
this little sister died of cancer on new
year's eve
oh my gosh i can't believe you brought
up leslie that is just so crazy
she's okay and she's they're all around
they're around your children
your kids are good your kids are really
good i
i just i can't okay wow
you had to marry him you know that right
you had to marry him not just for him
but for the family
from the moment i met this family i knew
that we would be together
forever and we really are and i'm so
glad because
you know what i realize is
families are just so you know if you put
the function and dysfunction
then you're really doing a great job and
if you have a sense of humor and
they're warm and they're affectionate
and they're worldly and we just all get
to be ourselves and everybody's
really appreciated for who they truly
are rather than
who they are supposed to be who's the
man with the h name
on your mother-in-law's side i think
it's an age oh my god
herzl her father did you know him no he
died before i was able to
join the family very a very hard-working
man
yes very hard working it's all about
he's saying
don't burn the candle at both ends make
sure you have
the time to balance yourself your free
time
everyone's laughing because everyone who
knows me knows i'm a
i'm yeah i don't know how to pace myself
yeah he'll help you because he
he couldn't help himself
whoa oh my god
and i can't tell you enough that i get
to go back
to my beautiful family and tell them how
ever present they
are and it makes all the sense because
they're what's at the forefront of my
life that's just so beautiful and so
wonderful and
so good for our for my daughters they're
they're their daughters and
granddaughters and
you know this is really all about olive
and frankie
so wow holy cow
oh my gosh i i hope
everyone has the benefit of speaking
to you uh
it was a honor and a pleasure to meet
you
i can't wait to go share this
information with people who will be so
moved by it
thank you holy cow